-Republicans
and right-wing pundits
have created a mythology that is
totally unmoored from reality,
in which Donald Trump
was the one
who was tough on Vladimir Putin
and would've somehow stopped
Putin from invading Ukraine.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
I feel like it's worth
taking a step back
and remembering the whole reason
Trump got impeached
the first time.
I know it's hard to remember
because Trump melted all
of our brains
by overloading us
with nonstop chaos and insanity.
History Channel's going to have
to launch its own version
of ESPN2,
called History Channel...
[ Laughter ]
[ Transatlantic accent ]
The year was 2019.
"Old Town Road" was
at the top of the charts
and everyone was buzzing
about the impeachment
of one Donald J. Trump.
Give 'em hell, Donald J.
[ Laughter ]
Trump got impeached specifically
because he tried
to extort Ukraine
to help him cheat
in the 2020 election
by holding up military aid
in a phone call with Ukraine's
President Volodymyr Zelenskyy,
the same Zelenskyy
who is now, once again,
asking the U.S.
for more military assistance.
If you'll recall, Zelenskyy
specifically asked Trump
to provide more
of an anti-tank missile system
known as a Javelin,
and that's when Trump tried
to dangle the military aid
over his head.
Zelenskyy told Trump...
To which Trump responded...
Remember that?
[ Laughter ]
It's not your fault
if you don't.
To find that transcript,
we had to send our researchers
down into the bowels of 30 Rock
with flashlights
and magnifying glasses
to sift through rolls
of microfiche,
like they were Nic Cage looking
for a secret code hidden
[ Laughter ]
on the back of the Constitution.
When they found it,
after weeks of searching,
they ran up to my office
with a little piece
of parchment in their hands,
and they said, "Mr. Meyers,
we found the transcript."
[ Laughter ]
And then I had to blow dust
just to read the words.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And then I said, "Dear God!
Do you know how old this is?
This happened all the way
back in
2019."
[ Suspenseful music climbs ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Lightning strikes,
thunder crashes ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
So Trump used the aid
Ukraine desperately wanted
as a bargaining chip
to empower himself politically
and, yet, yesterday,
after Zelenskyy's
virtual address to Congress
pleading for more aid,
House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy had the gall
to claim it was Joe Biden
who didn't give Ukraine
the military assistance
they were asking for.
-I've had conversations
with the president
long before this moment came.
My advice to him was provide
them the armament earlier
to deter Putin from ever making
these decisions.
The entire time,
President Biden always said
it would be the sanctions
afterwards.
And then,
when the sanctions came,
he said it'd take months
to work.
Well, Ukrainian people
cannot wait months.
-Are you for real?
Does your cable package not have
History Channel...?
[ Laughter ]
You're saying Biden is the one
who should've given Ukraine
the aid sooner?
The guy you supported tried
to extort Ukraine
like a mob boss counting singles
in the back room
of a strip club.
'Please, Mr. Trump, you can't
tell my wife I was here."
[ As Trump ]
That's no problem.
[ Laughter ]
That's no problem at all.
I would like you
to do us a favor, though.
I need you to help us plant
some dirt on the mayor.
You're going to tell people
he married his cousin.
[ As Giuliani ]
It's true. I did.
It was an accident.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And it was only for 14 years.
[ Laughter ]
I think these guys
genuinely believe
we don't remember
the Trump administration at all.
Maybe they thought that thing
Trump does with his hands
was a Jedi mind trick.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, Trump could never
pull off a Jedi mind trick
because he doesn't
have any focus.
[ As Trump ]
These are not the droids
you're looking for.
I got these droids
from my very good friend
Anakin Skywalker.
Big guy, strong guy.
Came up to me,
tears in his eyes.
He said, "Sir."
[ Laughter ]
He said, "Sir,
we love what you're doing
for the star system.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We love it.
You know he's Darth Vader now.
Anakin is Darth Vader.
Not a lot of people know that.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, you were looking
for some droids.
[ Laughter ]
They all want us to think Trump
magically would've fixed this
by being tough on Putin,
when we all know
the opposite was true.
Trump slobbered praise
all over Putin any chance he had
and was desperate to be
Putin's friend
and, yet, Trump apologists
continue to craft
this insane mythology where,
somehow,
Trump would've stopped Putin
from invading Ukraine.
Some of them have even come up
with elaborate allegories
to explain Trump's
supposed toughness.
-They didn't do this
on Trump's watch, Russia,
because Trump would've
kicked their ass.
-This never would've
happened under Trump.
-Why didn't Putin
do this
when Trump was president?
And I don't bring up
President Trump that much, okay?
[ Laughter ]
But I tell you right now
that he didn't do it
when Trump was president.
-What we are seeing
in Ukraine,
courtesy of Russia,
is merely a preview
of what can happen
when America signals weakness.
I've read that, in the jungles,
the mighty do not have to fight.
They say that,
when the bull elephant lives,
the herd is peaceful
and prosperous.
But in his absence,
confusion, disorder,
and destruction ensues.
Well, when I get
through speaking,
the next voice you hear will be,
in a little while,
will be that of our own
bull elephant, Donald Trump.
-Are you reading from a rejected
children's book
about Donald Trump?
[ Laughter ]
[ As McMaster ]
You see, the bull elephant lives
in the jungle
with all the others animals
and, when he's home,
the herd is peaceful.
And, because it is peaceful,
he has time to use Twitter.
But because he only has a trunk
to type with,
there are often misspellings
or things accidentally
in all-caps.
Still, he is an elephant
who tweets,
and that's pretty cool.
[ Laughter ]
Also, can we go back
to this real quick?
-I don't bring up
President Trump that much.
-Yeah, me neither.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Today is such a weird outlier.
[ Laughter ]
For what it's worth, I think
it's justified to bring him up.
He's the leader
of the Republican Party
and their likely nominee
in 2024.
But, yes, I do talk
about Trump a lot.
I even talked about him
when my psychiatrist
made me take an inkblot test,
but in my defense,
it did look like this.
[ Laughter ]
Bull elephant!
There was also another part
of that Jeanine Pirro tirade
I really enjoyed,
where she went off
on the Biden administration
for reaching out to social
media influencers on TikTok
to talk to them
about the war in Ukraine.
-Biden is responsible
for the decline of the West!
What we are seeing right now
is a --
I can't say the word --
is a wuss!
-[ Laughs ]
-We've got a bully in the yard,
in the playground yard,
in the schoolyard,
and everybody's back
at the fence, alright?
-How do you know --
-All we -- Wait, wait a minute.
Let me finish.
[ Laughter ]
All we have to do is
we have enough oil in Canada,
the United States, and Mexico
and we could be
our own superpowers,
but right now,
the Biden administration
is not only hurting
the Americans and all this
#BlamePutin TikTok nonsense.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-All this is crap!
-I'm sorry, I have to ask,
who is mixing your drinks?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Because, you know,
you're supposed
to put something nonalcoholic
in there too, right?
[ As Pirro ]
I'll have a vodka soda,
but replace the soda
with tequila
and replace the ice
with whiskey
and hold on.
Let me finish!
[ Laughter ]
Replaced the vodka
with more vodka!
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, Trump's sycophants
have all bought in
to the ludicrous idea
that Trump, somehow,
would've stopped Putin.
Trump himself has repeated
that claim on TV recently,
although he's been
weirdly vague about it.
-This would not have happened
during my administration.
In fact,
some people were saying,
"Why didn't this take place
over the last four years,
during our administration?"
And it didn't
for a very good reason,
and I'll explain that to you,
someday.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, well,
by all means,
keep that secret to yourself,
former U.S. president.
[ Laughter ]
That's like if, when COVID hit,
Obama said --
[ As Obama ]
Now, I got a cure,
and I'm going to tell you
what it is, uh...
when I'm good and ready.
[ Laughter ]
Trump treats foreign policy
like he's doing an ad
for women's perfume.
"What's our secret?
Maybe I'll tell you about it.
Some Day."
-Some Day by Calvin Klein.
[ Laughter ]
-And then this week,
Trump's half-finished
claymation sons
picked up where he left off,
[ Laughter ]
with Don Jr. suggesting
that Trump should meet
with NATO next week,
instead of Biden.
He tweeted...
Why would NATO want
to see Trump?
He repeatedly slammed NATO.
He's like their
WWE wrestling villain.
[ Laughter ]
Would they know he was there
when they heard
his entrance music?
[ German accent ]
So, we need to be careful
about what steps we take next,
as to not inflame tensions
-♪ Fun to stay at the ♪
-and, obviously --
-♪ YMCA ♪
-My God.
-♪ It's fun to stay at the ♪
-That's Donald Trump music!
-♪ YMCA ♪
[ Laughter ]
And then, Don Jr.'s copy
of a copy of a fax brother
Eric Trump
[ Laughter ]
went on TV and made
a similar claim,
but with even dumber reasons.
-Listen, my father would,
you know, call up
and he would've said,
"Vladimir,
don't even think about it.
Don't even try us.
I'm telling you, it's not going
to work out very well for you."
-You really think that's how
the conversation would go?
You sound like you're talking
to a dog
who's about to pee on the rug.
[ Laughter ]
Of course,
if Trump talked to a dog
the way he talked to Putin,
he would immediately give in
every time the dog complained.
[ As Trump ]
Sparky, don't do it.
Don't even think about it.
[ Laughter ]
Don't you dare.
Don't you dare pee on the rug,
or I'll have to shake that jar
full of loose change.
-[ Growling ]
-Or, or, alternatively,
pee wherever you want.
[ Laughter ]
This is your house, too, Sparky.
You're man's best friend
and that makes you
as much of a human as I am.
[ Laughter ]
Wizz away,
just not on the good rug.
-[ Growling ]
[ Laughter ]
-Or right in the middle
of the good rug.
[ Laughter ]
I was just saying to Melania,
I feel like this rug could use
a big, yellow, wet spot.
Now, we have it.
We worked together
and now, we have it, Sparky.
[ Laughter ]
In the last few days,
there's been
some cautious optimism
that a diplomatic solution
to this conflict
might be possible.
Even Zelenskyy himself
has hinted
at a possible compromise.
That's what we need to do --
help the millions of Ukrainians
who are suffering
and provide support
for a possible peace deal.
What we don't need are reckless
threats of escalation
from people who think Trump,
of all people,
would've put a stop to this.
The idea that Donald Trump
would've been tough
on Vladimir Putin is,
quite frankly...
-Bull.
-Crap!
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.